[Music]
in caught red-handed yes
is it here I can't do my laundry oh it
gives you miss her
of course only for that reason submitted
by Apple sucks okay those are cool what
the [ __ ]
big days grand a month a cup yeah that's
why I looked at y'all I just used it cuz
it's there I love Apple I love that cuz
we're talking about the fruit it's one
of my least favorite fruits if we're
talking about the company it's okay did
you know they made it exciting in
kindergarten cuz they were like here are
all the different apples which one do
you like the most Mouse at Clancy's
minute this is tasty
oh yes the sole which was oh is that the
worry no I want a degree that's my
chance you like it that's the only way I
like them dipped in peanut butter
give it to me anyway this hour I know
it's a love it cuz I love that sour
stuff but then recently I'm the best way
to have a granny smith apple is in a
[ __ ] pie that's it oh yeah is good I
was a kid I didn't know that it was
gonna be sour I took a bite of that [ __ ]
and I throw it away and I was like never
again it's cuz we always have the red in
the [ __ ] Fuji apples that's the one I
like that was hella good get in there
I'm sorry a mom would be who's lunch
kept getting stolen at work
catches thief and has her fired hell
yeah read this dude if somebody stole my
[ __ ] lunch I get the fired to hell
yeah I would just put diuretics inside
so then when they eat it they actually
you know what I'm like I wouldn't get
them was this was this the the reddit
one or in she worked out like a
corporation or something like that
to be honest you know what I would do if
somebody kept still on my lunch I would
actually feel happy that they enjoy my
food that much Oh
what don't you be starving now I would
guess but I would just kind of be like
shut the [ __ ] up don't try to sound like
you're all understanding and [ __ ] you'd
be like what yeah but then at the same
time I like cooking food for people so
like if they're stealing my food
specifically that means my shits good
dude put a camera in the lunchroom
well you know what I would do I would
get because most companies you have like
a laptop or something I would get my
laptop I would go in the kitchen I would
wear it this
guys like a mask maybe a ski mask you
know and I would sit there and I would
wait patient you would not stand out one
bit
no no maybe just like a nice mini I do I
destroy I would I would like Polly could
put caca or some kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
in the food and at the very end of the
plate it will say you just ate some [ __ ]
homeboy so then don't eat everything and
at the end they'll be like Oh what does
it say you just a some [ __ ] have you
ever seen the one where I love that [ __ ]
whoever's been drinking my almond milk
congratulations you've been drinking my
breast milk oh yeah
you just ate some [ __ ] that's not mad
picture the guy just eating your food
he's like oh that was so delicious his
eyes is ulis together do you say some
[ __ ] homeboy yeah staring at it yes you
wanted to steal a pregnant woman too
that says two people yeah cuz baby name
nutrients she posted on reddit that
someone at her job kept stealing her
lunch and her husband is a chef so the
food's amazing
oh yeah and so she began to label the
food hoping that it would deter the
thief but it didn't and she eventually
put a note on the fridge saying please
stop taking my food I am pregnant and
breastfeeding and this is negatively
affecting my health so she wrote what
the [ __ ] spider two kids so she's got
work plug again her titties all pumped
and she's hungry as [ __ ] and she's all
mad dude when you're breastfeeding
you're starving
you need already yeah it's like they're
taking the [ __ ] food from your
stomach and it comes out of your tit and
you're like oh my god I need it in
you're so dehydrated those little demons
dude
they'd suck the life out of you but
they're soaked I'm pretty cute
hope you enjoy that meal you little
[ __ ] I love you that's why they're cute
wig when I was breastfeeding cuz I
stopped eating like I did when I was
pregnant and I just lost so much I was
so unhealthy
you still don't eat hay actually I
gained a lot of weight where in your
hair you know you look skinny is up real
good though that's why if babies weren't
cute everybody liked [ __ ] is too much
work there's some out there though
Oh cute - Ben that is true that's up
beauties and I have the holder because
Bob because it looks like them and
people just want mini Dems and then
they're just like oh my god I'm taking
care of myself and it's so cute I like
the cute the cute version of me oh my
god I'm so [ __ ] up I was at Mariel's
house and there's this picture of this
ugly little boy [ __ ] a picture of
marital as a kid that's me I was like
that's me don't say that dude that's
mean yeah my kid's gonna be [ __ ] up
looking good for sure I might try my
best not to make fun I'll have your back
thank you oh my god kid you look so good
but if I left my tissue just like daddy
would he was a kid [ __ ] all just
sticky and [ __ ] all right so this woman
she had the IT guys put install cameras
awesome so the thief was caught in the
act and it turned out to be an older
woman who was up for promotion so she's
a name what a piece of [ __ ] she makes
like way more than this woman make why
can't you just get her own [ __ ] like
stealing probably not even eating the
food probably just didn't well I think I
did read this I think she didn't like
her or something like that like it so
you think she took it and threw it away
she knew yeah who the food blonde you
seen me because I'm like how did you
figure that out every day like she
hadn't been standing by the fridge every
day just sipping the coffee waiting to
see what Tupperware was yours you know
how'd she have all the time she's not
exactly much I hate somebody I still
can't take food from a pregnant woman
because what does that child have to do
with that individual
you know you'd if I hate someone I
wouldn't do that [ __ ] I pledge me in the
face yeah that's more direct yeah yeah
so she so the pregnant woman said that
that older woman is making triple what
she's making damn and then so after a
week of that because she had written
green
now just to keep them at her desk to
hold her over so then she had the IT
guys sent her a screen shot of her
stealing one from each day so then
specifically her
yeah it was specifically the pregnant
lady's lunch so then uh she was she was
explaining that once you're up at this
executive level there are executives
from the headquarters that fly down to
meet up with the execs in the office and
then sit down and then bomb-ass meals in
the cover in the presentations from the
interviewees that are up for that
promotion so she said that she said in
one of those meetings hell yeah as a
note-taker
and then she changed one of the slides
for the food thief the presentation
which was a photo of her stealing the
food out of the fridge
turned back to look at the screen and
then she was just like in horror and
that's what all the execs already knew
about the whole lunch situation that
they were being stolen they were visibly
so pissed at her and then it turned out
that one of the execs
who worked at the headquarters was also
pregnant and then another one had a wife
who had just had a baby oh they were
just extra sympathetic yeah she ended up
getting fired let me let me let me tell
you the reason why you know why I think
that was Patty we know why she didn't
want it to get to that level like go to
HR you know why I love you know I don't
know what she's doing because I like
when people get motive and it's like in
your face you [ __ ] yeah I like that I
like that I love that [ __ ] you know
what's hard that kind of pity is like
the nice like calculated petty in a
company though you know what the hard
part is just just because you go to HR
it doesn't mean that things are gonna be
dealt with because people develop
relationships within that company and at
that ladies in the exec that [ __ ] was
not gonna get dealt with she was just
gonna get a little tap on the wrist
don't do it again and then take a change
if a high-power female executive is
doing that to a pregnant lady you know
what that sounds like jello see she
loves you know why cuz she's an older
lady she might have had to skip or her
chances of marriage and having a baby
and all that stuff because one of the
biggest reasons why there aren't that
many female executives is because women
have to make that choice she
I have a family and a baby or should I
become a powerful executive and then she
might be looking at her like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] which a [ __ ] pregnant
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] well the
pregnant baby was they mean yeah or the
or the pregnant lady was just mean to
her yeah David has a really good point
but late just Austin to me like I like
and I saw it happen over that Guti but
then I'd also be like you know the woman
that was getting her lunch so and I was
like we're so [ __ ] petty like true it
just should have had for me yeah both
just petty and like my fingers like I
kind of work like oh oh I hear about
this [ __ ] no way why don't you get your
lunch stolen hear that [ __ ] I don't know
have you ever been hangry in your life
yeah my [ __ ] my [ __ ] wife made me
some bomb-ass and you're like I can't
wait and you open up the fridge you're
like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] where's
my [ __ ] casserole what the [ __ ]
we can you imagine the first three days
of this happening it like it would
probably to her for like a it's like a
mistake
Oh someone took it Boop it's fine fine
I'll take I'll do it again boom gets it
happen it happens someone takes it again
someone takes it what are you gonna do
get McDonald's every day yeah like a
third time I should put signs up and I'm
gonna take it I'm thinking did she get
her tupperware back oh she probably lost
that she would make her pay me back for
the Tupperware that he'd cooked though
it must have been so delicious
what if he's a chef for like RVs what
hold us what if he's like a Michelin
star chef and he's like making some bomb
a [ __ ] and they're like can you blame me
though this shit's so good and in his
shares it with everyone too like Astro
where they come with taking lunch for
somebody is it's kind of difficult
because if you try to be creative cuz
you have to figure out something but
you're gonna make that's gonna taste
good after you refrigerate it that's
like the challenge right so you have
this very limited in what you could make
do you do that now for Mariel I've been
making your lunch for the past three
weeks straight and what do you would
make so it depends right so if I'm in
like this whole Japanese Korean mood
right now so I made it like kimchi
jjigae I made that's good afternoon
micro event yeah a lot of those steel
type stuff with uh with uh
cut the chicken katsu yeah and then I
did a soup yaki beef yeah and then I did
aqua : I did all this other stuff so
that tastes really good microwave didn't
like Japanese food is really good for
that yeah you could reheat it so just
whatever I saw it like Japan 7-eleven
like imitating it and they're putting it
in a blood so she Mexican food has to be
fresh yeah it's going done after the
first day saw me oh yes soups always for
sure but soups are difficult to kind of
travel with
[Music]